bonsoir à toutes et à tous nous
attendons vos questions sms internet et
réseaux sociaux pour alimenter notre
discussion les verts sont au bord de la
fracture la question de leur retour au
gouvernement
déchirant réalité le parti écolo comme
toujours la fermeture de fessenheim ou
encore l'engagement à baisser la part de
l'énergie nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité fait partie des gages de
bonne volonté donné par françois
hollande à ses alliés écolos mais nous
sommes en campagne électorale et nicolas
sarkozy s'est emparé du sujet il accuse
le président de brader la filière
nucléaire pour un simple accord
politique nucléaire sarkozy attaque
c'est le titre de cette émission avec
nous pour en parler aujourd'hui corinne
lepage
vous êtes présidente du rassemblement
citoyen cap21 vous êtes également
avocate vous avez été ministre de
l'environnement et eurodéputé je cite
votre dernier livre l'état nucléaire aux
éditions albin michel
jean marc jancovici vous êtes ingénieur
enseignant à paris une tech confondateur
de carbone cat un cabinet de conseil
spécialisé dans la stratégie carbone
votre dernier ouvrage transition
énergétique pour tous est publié chez
odile jacob daniel bois vous êtes
politologue directeur de recherche au
cevipof le laboratoire politiques de
sciences po spécialiste de l'écologie
politique je cite votre livre sur le
grenelle de l'environnement qui est
publié chez armand colin
enfin jacques percebois économiste
professeur à l'université de montpellier
où vous dirigez le centre de recherche
en économie et droit de l'énergie vous
avez présidé nous y reviendrons la
commission énergie 2050 sur les
perspectives de la filière nucléaire
et enfin vous êtes l'auteur de énergie
économie et politique aux éditions de
boeck
nicolas sarkozy a lancé l' attaque le
sujet nucléaire redevient c'est pas la
première fois un sujet politique je me
tourne vers vous corinne lepage elle est
de droite
le nucléaire cette droite non le
nucléaire je dirais que c'est
consubstantiel à l'état et à l'immense
majorité de la classe politique
française c'est à dire c'est
consubstantiel à tous les français c'est
une autre affaire voilà donc ce n'est
pas une affaire de droite ou de gauche
mais c'est un débat politique récurrente
à vrai débat politique et je dirais
surtout ça devient un débat économique
et financier à mon avis avant même que
d'être politique jean marc jancovici ça
vous surprend que le débat se fond se
terminent toujours de cette manière là
parce que les choses n'avancent pas
pendant qu on s'affronte sur le
nucléaire ça dépend ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle avancer et ça dépend ce qu'on
poursuit c'est à dire qu'on a toujours
l'impression de reposer les mêmes
questions et d'assister au même débat
oui mais c'est le saas est assez normal
parce que dans la mesure où les
installations nucléaires dur des
décennies ça peut faire des décennies de
débats donc le nom le nucléaire est le
principal sujet dont on débat en france
quand il est question d'énergie parce
que c'est le seul domaine dans lequel on
a des installations de production
nationale comme on n'a pas ou peu de
puits de pétrole sur notre sol comme on
n'a pas ou peu de puits de gaz sur notre
sol et comme on n'a plus de mines de
charbon en france le nucléaire est le
seul domaine dont on parle parce qu'il
ya des objets qui sont situés en france
qui sont visibles qui peuvent être
montrées à la télévision ce qui a son
rôle et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
focalise les débats énergétique sur
cette question du nucléaire
par ailleurs elle a aussi l'avantagé
pour elle cette question de permettre
d'incarner un débat que les médias
adorent qui est le petit con plus gros
ce qui est difficile avec ça marche
toujours ça je disais en jouant un peu
la provoc le nucléaire cette droite il
ya moins de débats au sein de la droite
sur la question nucléaire
non c'est daniel bois vous assure que ce
soit aussi simple que ça non mais moi je
ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord et
corinne lepage parce que au niveau de la
classe politique je reconnais qu'il ya
une certaine homogénéité au niveau du
public à des vraies différences
gauche-droite un sensible n'a pas
seulement les écolos qui sont très très
très opposés au nucléaire il ya un
gradient d'opposition ou de ou
d'acceptation du nucléaire maintenant de
plus en plus entre gauche et droite qui
est très très clair un vrai clivage
conduit donc à passer entre la droite et
la gauche
société la société pas dans la classe
politique est politique c'est plus
discutable je reconnais parce que même à
l'intérieur du ps on sait bien que c'est
un peu compliqué mais je n'irai pas pour
autant qu'ils sont oui pardon daniel
bois vous dire aujourd'hui que c'est un
sujet qui structure la classe politique
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
c'est votre sujet sa structure pas la
classe politique ça transcende dans la
classe politique là je suis d'accord
c'est à dire qu'il ya des traits
nucléariste au ps il étrenne une crise à
l'ump
donc il ya un petit peu de tout ça
transcende les chaussées dans la société
que ça qu'on avant une vraie dimension
gauche-droite ralentir la classe
politique c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
mais vous qui êtes des spécialistes du
sujet est ce qu'à un moment donné ça
vous agace pas de voir comment au fond
est toujours abordé le débat sur sur le
nucléaire jacques percebois c'est un
débat important parce que le nucléaire
c'est quand même un élément je dirais de
l'autonomie énergétique de la france
d'un accès aux prix de l'écrit site est
relativement bas et je répondrai que
c'est pas un choix de droite ou de
gauche parce que vous trouvez des
pro-nucléaires aussi bien au ps qu'au
parti communiste d'ailleurs le parti
communiste a souvent été un pilier un
pilier du nucléaire français donc vous
avez d'ailleurs verrez que vous reprenez
l'histoire du développement du nucléaire
en france
là je dirais le le meilleur soutien des
programmes nucléaires français en dehors
de la droite fait particulièrement deux
parties du ps ça a été le parti
communiste et la cgt indiscutable hélas
les clivages ne bouge pas il ya pas
d'évolution sur ce sujet là on
al'impression pardon mais que sait-on
kyste et les pros et les antis les
lobbyistes et ce qui est celle qu'un
cellule même l'objet de votre livre je
trouve sur le tas n'a pas vraiment un
débat c'est à dire que le sujet
nucléaire revient périodiquement
généralement par la petite porte ces
termes on ferme face au nein on enferme
pas fessenheim qui est un sujet mais qui
est pas le sujet majeur
le vrai sujet c'est ce qu'on continue
avec une filière nucléaire importante
dans les années qui viennent
ou est-ce qu'on programme l'arrêt
progressif du nucléaire en france c'est
ça le le sujet de fond et en fait on à
bord on n'arrive pas à aborder
franchement sujet on ne demande jamais
aux français s'ils sont d'accord pour
qu'on construise de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires en france
ce qui pour moi est quand même le vrai
sujet et le sujet économique et
financier je reviens là dessus parce que
pour moi c'est aujourd'hui un des points
majeurs avec le risque peut-être qu'on
en reparlera ce sujet là il n'est pas de
traiter et quand on parle de l'allemagne
le parfait contre-exemple on entend en
france oui mais vous comprenez fond du
charbon donc ce qu'ils font est nul
c'est à dire qu'on a un débat 0 sur le
plan de la capacité de nos concitoyens
de pouvoir juger réellement
de quoi il est question mais comment
elles sont les coureurs à prendre parce
que les françaises qui voit c'est que
depuis la fin des années 70 on a fait du
nucléaire et que ça a permis de faire la
france aussi ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est vrai mais ce qui était vrai en
1960 n'est pas forcément voire 2015 cet
appareil on a changé de siège la une des
choses qu'on n'arrive pas à faire dans
ce pays
c'est alors qu'on est au pays de
descartes c'est de commencer par poser
l'objet du débat c'est à dire que vous
ne voyez nulle part le nucléaire c'est
quoi si vous demandez aux français de
vous expliquer comment fonctionne une
centrale nucléaire il faudrait faire le
sondage je pense que vous allez en
trouver n'importe quoi entre 1 et 5% qui
sont capables de vous donner c'est quand
vous aussi vous demander s'il y a que 5
% des chirurgiens du foie qui savent ce
que c'est qu'un fois c'est quand même un
peu ennuyeux de leur confier votre foi
là on va demander aux français de
centrales fiba avoir espéré avoir un
avis informer sur quelque chose dont
vous ne comprenez pas le fonctionnement
c'est quand même ennuyeux quelque part
non donc il ya or ce dès ce débat a
simplement pour expliquer de quoi on
parle et quelque chose qui a énormément
de mal à prendre place et je vais vous
le sorcier une anecdote en 2003 j'étais
président d'un comité consultatif sur la
précédente version du débat national sur
l'énergie et j'avais proposé que le
débat commence par un peu de
vulgarisation sur ce qu'est l'énergie
les cinq représentants des associations
écolos m'ont volé dans les plumes en
disant vous n'y pensez pas c'est de la
manipulation on ne peut pas faire un
truc comme ça n'est qu'un jeu j étais
donc je peux vous le dire
donc le sait c'est très très difficile
sur ces débats qui sont devenus affectif
de dire stop on arrête tout on peut les
héros on va simplement décrire l'objet
du débat et ensuite on recommencera à
disputer pour savoir si on en a envie
souvent vite et est du coup le truc
l'histoire se répète indéfiniment et sur
la base de choses qui sont pour partie
vrai pour partie faussé je vais finir un
passant témoin à daniel bois qui fait
tous les ans un sondage sur les
perceptions des français sur l'effet de
serre un français sur deux pense que le
nucléaire contribuer significativement
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
reproche est ce qu'on fait notre ère
donc le donc le débat il est sur des
bases où les gens donnent eux n'ont pas
simplement est-ce que vous dire je le
débat il se fait aussi beaucoup sur la
peur ceux ci parlent
ceci va avec cela vous savez quand vous
comprenez pas quelque chose dont on a
toujours un peu peur c'est le cas avec
le nucléaire
oui ce qui me frappe dans cette affaire
le débat reprenez le grenelle de
l'environnement qui était quand même le
débat qu'on considérait comme le grand
débat sur l'environnement de l'apprendre
durable pourquoi il a fonctionné parce
qu'on en a exclu nucléaire améliorer
dans des raisons de politique
on a eu un feu vert ou une grande
négociation que à condition qu'on en
sorte nucléaire et quant au débat sur la
transition énergétique de mon point de
vue il a je suis d'accord avec corinne
lepage on a on a finalement il ya eu ce
deal entre le ps et les verts qui était
dit ah bon voilà on va réduire à 50% en
2025 sans expliquer absolument comment
on va s'y prendre et surtout sans que
soient posés la question cruciale
et après voilà on en construit où on en
construit pas quand les centrales vont
arriver à 40 ans c'est pas très
difficile à savoir vos habitations une
feuille excel vous rajoutez les années
vous arrivez à combien la vie à deux
centrales à 40 ans il ya aucune
discussion là dessus du feu débat il
n'est pas ouvert sur le vrai mais est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour dire qu'en
plus ce débat il peut pas se dérouler
sereinement parce qu'à un moment donné
dans la discussion
on vit en vient à parler de fukushima
est ce que ça a changé totalement
jacques percebois la façon dont les
français les spécialistes mêmes
perçoivent ou et appréhendent le sujet
du nucléaire est le débat du nucléaire
oui absolument aussi bien sur mobile que
fukushima lé peut être plus fukushima
que tchernobyl était que tchernobyl
c'était soviétique
beaucoup de gens expliqué que c'était
pas c'était plus un accident soviétique
entre guillemets cas d'accident
nucléaire
par contre fukushima ça se passait au
japon un pays je dirais de l' ocde qui
en principe prendre toutes les
précautions dont fukushima
ça a plombé pas mal de nucléaire bon ce
qu'on observe c'est que à l'heure
actuelle du caire quand même reparti
dans le monde il est faux de dire tous
les pays sortent de nucléaire vous avez
72 réacteurs en construction dans le
monde
je signale que tout récemment le jambon
en construction construction de certains
étaient en temps de bail parce que le
japon vient de décider et à deux jours
de reprendre la construction des 28
réacteurs qu'ils avaient mis en stand by
donc ça prouve s'il voulait qu'il ya des
pays qui veulent y venir donc il ya des
pics ont renoncé au nucléaire il ya des
pays qui ont maintenu le nucléaire des
pays qui veulent rentrer dans le
nucléaire dont vous avez aujourd'hui je
dirais sur la palette des choix qui sont
il ya des pays qui débattent comme
l'alliance et le sujet on y
fermer fessenheim françois hollande a
une nouvelle fois réaffirmé son
engagement avec un calendrier l'horizon
de la fin du quinquennat la fermeture de
la plus vieille centrale en activité du
parc nucléaire français est devenu un
sujet d'affrontement politique sur place
le débat est réel ces manifestations
contre manifestation nicolas sarkozy
s'est rendu à fessenheim pour dénoncer
les conséquences d'un éventuel
démantèlement de la centrale reportage à
lisa coudray et stéphane lopez comme un
air de déjà vu nicolas sarkozy en
campagne au chevet des salariés de
fessenheim sauver cette centrale
on voit là sans vie ensemble ouais c'est
sûr tout ça que je suis là je sauver la
centrale même promesse qu'en 2012 mêmes
adversaires aussi
sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est françois
hollande le président et il a encore
réaffirmé il ya quelques jours
fessenheim fermera ses portes avant la
fin de son mandat monsieur hollande veut
la fermer pour des raisons économiques
non bien sûr
pour des raisons stratégiques non bien
sûr uniquement parce qu'il veut mendier
quelques voix à des écologistes engagés
dans un combat politicien
fessenheim encore une fois au coeur
d'une bataille politique pro en pis tous
l'ont bien compris
chacun tente de se faire entendre samedi
dernier les antinucléaires s'étaient
donné rendez-vous à strasbourg environ
500 manifestants inquiet car ici
personne n'a totalement confiance en la
promesse du président de la république
il tient compte quand même de ségolène
royal c'est un peu normal elle est le
ministre de l'écologie et la ministre de
l'énergie pour ségolène royal change
d'avis chaque jour qui passe un jour
elle vante la filière nucléaire le
lendemain elle dit qu'elle fermera fait
même le troisième jour elle dit que ça
sera peut-être une autre centrale au nom
qu'on en fait rien elle évite beaucoup
elle attend la décision d'aider f
il ya urgence parce que cette centrale
depuis à son âge aurait dû était déjà
arrêté depuis longtemps elle est trop
ancien pro âgées elle n'est plus à l'âge
du temps et de plus elle est bâtie sur
une faille sismique et sous le canal
d'alsace ce qui augmente
considérablement les risques d'accident
quelques jours plus tard direction
colmar
ce jour là se réunit la clis la
commission locale d'information et de
surveillance
élus associations experts indépendants
trois fois par an la commission
interroge les représentants d'edf sur
les questions de sécurité
à l'ordre du jour l'incident de la
semaine dernière
une fuite dans la salle des machines qui
a obligé la centrale a stoppé quelques
jours son unité de production
les militants écologistes interpelle le
directeur du site
j'ai reçu un des graphes de mesures de
radioactivité dans des stationnements
qu'une gamme pour design et d'un séjour
et ce qui me surprend c'est que
justement un pic de radioactivité en
sieverts par heure le 27 février au
petit peu avant midi je veux savoir
c'est pouvoir un lien avec ce qui s'est
passé soit sur le réacteur 1 soit sur
directeur 2 qui pourrait expliquer cette
augmentation de l'activité mesurée sur
grisaille et fribourg donc ça se joindre
à ce qu'ils soient officiels de
plusieurs branches peux dire c'est que
nous avons des propositions à l'iran se
lire comme ça sur ma lancée et monsieur
aucun problème
selon edf on voit quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes autour des
questions de sécurité
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux citoyens
qui sont incrits je pense je j'ai
répondu aux questions qui sont posées en
crise je vous remercie et qui sont
légitimes
les des questions qui sont posées on y
répond
merci nous sommes encore et toujours
obligés de défendre ce site
face à l'acharnement des antinucléaires
qui retrouverait en france en hollande
maillon faible salariés habitant les
défenseurs de fessenheim eux continuent
à y croire ici en cas de fermeture plus
de 2000 emplois sont menacés et monsieur
le maire l'assurent il n'y a aucun plan
de reconversion
il n'y a pas de plan b c'est un mythe
parce qu'en des menteurs
retransformer la centrale en site de
démantèlement d'excellence 1 2 chez pas
quoi tout ça c'est la pilule pour faire
avaler le reste c'est le donc mais du
jour au lendemain c'est des centaines
d'emplois en moins il ira sur le site
pendant quelques années peut-être une
cinquantaine dont une centaine
d'employés c'est tours qui sont la
surveillance alors fermeture ou pas
quelle qu'elle soit la décision sera
politique
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire elle a
autorisé la centrale à poursuivre ses
activités jusqu'en 2023 et je vous pose
cette question d'un téléspectateur tel
qu'on l'a entendu à fessenheim nicolas
sarkozy at il une idée précise de notre
avenir énergétique ont fêté
systématiquement de lentilles aux
langues
non je crois que c'est un fou du
nucléaire oui carrément
je pense qu'ils les fanatiques du
nucléaire on l'a vu quand il voulait
vendre des centrales nucléaires à
monsieur kadhafi
je pense qu'il a le il trouve que le
nucléaire alors pour des raisons qui
peuvent être légitimes que c'est
vraiment l'alpha et l'oméga nous c'est
pas raisonnable parce que c'est
totalement déraisonnable je pense que
fessenheim effectivement il ya une
autorisation puisque l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire a dit que ça allait
jusqu'en 2023
personnellement mais vous c'est que j'ai
une double casquette puisque j'ai
défendu les gens qui demandaient la
fermeture
quand je dis les gens c'est quand même
près d'un million de personnes parce que
c'est toutes les collectivités locales
françaises suisses et allemandes qui
sont au voisinage
donc c'est quand même pas 3 écolo dans
un coin c'est parce que c'est une
centrale qui est considéré par tous les
autres comme extrêmement dangereuse à
telle enseigne que la secrétaire d'état
à l'environnement allemande est venu sur
le site pour réclamer la fermeture de
cette centrale
si c'est nous étions en allemagne elle
cette centrale elle serait fermée du
pilote pas s'arrêter là dessus s'il vous
plaît on va s'arrêter sur ce point
précis ça fait des années qu'on entend
fessenheim c'est dangereux pourquoi
c'est dangereux selon vous alors je vous
dis dans le détail c'est pas madame
lepage qu'il faut le demander à la
bastille chacun sont aussi savoureuses
histoires je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
et pardonnez moi mais là aujourd'hui
nous sommes regardés sur ce plateau donc
on va quand même d'aider leur image de
jancovici mais vous serez obligé de me
supporter voilà c'est extrêmement ça
vous avez une centrale qui est
construite dans une zone sismique
puisqu'elle est à proximité de bâle où
il ya eu un tremblement de terre en 1354
lorsqu'on a construit fessenheim envers
les années
soixante dix on a pris une référence sur
l'échelle de richter qui était à
l'époque de 6,2 et on a mis un
coefficient de sécurité de 0,5 ça fait 6
sauf que trente ans plus tard on a
réévalué le tremblement de terre de
balle et on dit aujourd'hui c'est autour
de cette donc on est en dessous premier
point deuxième point c'est une centrale
qui a été construit en contrebas du
canal du rhin à 8 m ce qui veut dire que
s'il ya une rupture de digue s'est
automatiquement une centrale qui est
inondé
ça c est vous pouvez faire tout ce que
vous voulez sur votre centrale que le
risque sismique et le risque inondation
il est inévitable bon troisièmement
c'est effectivement une centrale qui est
construite sur la nappe phréatique la
plus importante d'europe d'où
l'énervement de nos voisins parce que
s'il ya une pollution c'est toute la
nappe rhénane qui est qui est pollué
vous ajoutez à ça une seule en scène de
confinement pas deux vous ajoutez à ça
pas de tour de réfrigération vous
ajoutez à ça pas d'autorisation sur les
rejets chimiques
ça fait quand même beaucoup c'est une
foultitude d'incidents lagon 615 sont
ailleurs on y voit là pour se crêper le
chignon et pour retomber dans les
travers qu'on dénonce donc chacun d'eux
tout juste il vous dit ça c'est
convaincant et en même temps on à
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui nous
dit mais non il n'y a pas de problème
cette centrale peut fonctionner encore
dix ans jusqu'en 2023 donc pardon les
gens qui nous regardent aujourd'hui ses
disques y croire bien la chance d'avoir
une autorité sûreté nucléaire
indépendantes et compétentes à
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a dit
sous réserve de faire un centre de
travaux quand même donc et des travaux
engagés au niveau de fessenheim
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a donné
son accord
donc elle croit en compte ces données
elle prend en compte les éléments je
lire les légendes autorisé que les gens
qui nous écoutent se pose quand même la
question vous prenez des gens qui sont
dans un bon dans une entité qui a pour
seule mission pour seule mission de
savoir si les installations peuvent
fonctionner ou non et sous quelles
conditions
quelque chose qui vient d'être énoncé en
2 minutes 30 vous pensez qu'ils en ont
tenu aucun compte
ils peuvent prendre les gens pour des
andouilles que le dire ça non pas du
tout je vous ai pas interrompu donc en
cet éléphant monsieur jancovici sied
donc la finale par interrompue donc je
répète c'est évident que ces gens-là
intègre un certain nombre d'éléments
on cela ils rendent des avis
circonstancié qui tiennent pas en un
quart de page
donc la seule conclusion à tirer si on
pense que cette centrale est dangereuse
à là où la première en tout cas c'est
dire et tout le monde à l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire alors qu'est ce que
vous répondez aux risques de
tremblements de terre et d'inondations
mais que c'est en mai que s'est intégrée
dans la manière dont doit fonctionner
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire dont il
faut lire non mais il faut lire leur
production ce que je confesse ne pas
avoir fait les regarder tous les
attendus des décisions qui sont dedans
pour vérifier que un certain nombre
d'éléments ce ont été pris en compte
personnellement c'est pas mon job donc
j'ai pas été regardé par contre je le
répète s'il ya une suspicion légitime
sur le fait que cette autorité autorise
des installations alors qu'elles ne
devraient pas la première conclusion
quand vous n'avez pas confiance en votre
médecin la première chose que vous
faites c'est en changer si ces gens là
ces gens là bâti ces gens là on peut
tout à fait en changer donc si ces gens
là n'ont pas la compétence nécessaire
pour regarder la seule conclusion à en
tirer c'est qu'il faut changer
mais ce qui vous agace on revient vous
êtes agacé qu'est ce qui vous agace dans
cette façon de présenter un débat qui on
est légitime à se poser avec nos voisins
allemands et européens si une centrale
qui est vieillissant au débat est tout à
fait légitime
ce qui est si vous agace alors elle est
pas celle accusations sans preuve donc
quand madame lepage accuse un jeu
original ma phrase accuse l'autorité
sûreté nucléaire de ne pas tenir compte
d'un certain nombre d'éléments qu'elle
vient dénoncer moi je dis c'est une
accusation sans preuve
pas du tout cet objectif je veux dire
qu'on va pas le changer quelques
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire dit ça
fait 30 ans que ça dure comme sur leur
propre concours des éléments mais
l'énoncé
tout simplement parce que c'est un fait
monsieur jancovici
il entraîne son 20e but comment est-ce
que vous expliquer ce que j'ai dis quand
même parfaitement aux objectifs parce
que l'autorité de sûreté à giles et
faire changer aux accusés où sont les
changes oui mais voilà le voulais je
vais jusqu'au bout
lorsque l'autorité de sûreté dit à edf
vous allez faire des études
complémentaires pour voir ça mais ça ça
existe que je suis en train de dire je
sais que vous défendez edf alors raillé
pour eux mais c'est pas une raison pour
pas me laisser parler
ouais on en revient toujours aux aigus
comme c'est la loose
là et l'autre la démonstration sont
simples pour être pour un souci c'est le
bois ne paye pas ses impôts
non moi je vais je vous répondrai
simplement deux choses vous avez une
étude que je vous enverrai grand plaisir
qui a été fait par l'état de westphalie
en allemagne qui établit très clairement
que la sécurité est par nature nucléaire
non mais vous me dites vous avez le
choix
pas d'accord que l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire moi je vous dis alors s'il
vous plaît monsieur jancovici c'est pas
notre sujet on se perd on sait on s'est
garé sur tous les gens qui vous
regardent ne comprennent plus rien
question très simple et eu un
tremblement de terre il ya 700 ans à mal
oui ca condamne km est-ce que ça l'est
vraiment en danger
quand la centrale a été construite à cet
endroit là évidemment qu'on a pris en
compte ce risque de séismes ont répondu
simplement ce que je dis c'est que et
l'autorité de sûreté il peut rien c'est
qu'en trente ans les connaissances ont
progressé et que le niveau de ce
tremblement de terre a été réévaluée que
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire dit bon
ben ok dont acte c'est possible il n'en
reste pas moins que ce que je dis est
totalement objectif jacques percebois
est-ce qu'on avait anticipé le tsunami
est-ce qu'on avait anticipé on avait
simulé ce qui pouvait se passer en cas
d'inondation d'une centrale on avait
anticipé un tsunami mais pas sonné mais
aussi important c'est vrai sur fukushima
faut bien voir que le tremblement de
terre
la centrale les centrales ont résisté le
problème c'était le tsunami qui est
passé par dessus s'ils voulaient donc
c'est ensuite d'autres questions qui se
sont qui se sont posés par ce qu'on
n'ait pas anticipé que la vague frais je
crois c'est neuf mètres qu'on avait
pensé qu'elle ferait moins donc un homme
le je pense je pense que depuis
fukushima les autorités de sûreté
nucléaires notamment l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire française qui a la
réputation d'être compétentes à
l'échelle internationale je dirais à
regarder tous les arguments alors on
peut évidemment personne ne peut donner
une garantie absolue à 100% qui se
passera jamais rien de même que
dans n'importe quel domaine industriel
c'est vrai dans la chimie c'est vrai
dans l'aviation serait dans tous les
domaines ceci étant je pense que depuis
fukushima
des études complémentaires ont été fait
d'ailleurs des désinvestissements et
effets à la demande de l'asn de
l'autorité sûreté nucléaire a fait part
à fessenheim donc des investissements ne
serait ce que pour prolonger la durée de
vie de fessenheim il a fallu qu'edf
acceptent des investissements donc dans
l'état actuel des choses je dirais la
probabilité
elle était alors réservé un incident des
failles à la 0 ceci étant je pense que
l'asn vu ce qui s'est passé à fukushima
ne prendrait pas le risque de liesse
deux arguments qui poserait des
problèmes donnez moi il ya deux
arguments qui sont des veaux qu'étant
dans ce débat quand on parle de
fessenheim ya la question de l'emploi en
2000 emplois menacés et il ya aussi la
question du coût du démantèlement alors
prenons ces sujets les uns après les
autres
est ce que la question de l'emploi c'est
majeur en ce moment dans dans ce pays sa
part 1 au téléspectateur on supprimerait
2000 emplois en fermant cette centrale
et pions on réduira considérablement
l'activité économique de la région
est ce que ça vous l'entendez dans le
débat où est-ce que ça doit pas peser
selon vous on l'entend mais je pense que
c'est pas l'argument principal sous les
2 mêmes qu'on fait une force de
dissuasion ou qu'on fait une armée pour
défendre un territoire ont fait pas une
armée pour créer des emplois
on fait pas une politique énergétique
pour créer des emplois si ça crée des
emplois tant mieux l'important c'est
d'avoir une politique énergétique qui a
pour objectif d'approvisionner un pays
dans les meilleures conditions avec une
sécurité d'approvisionnement
alors on fait des choix ces choix sont
créateurs d'emplois directs indirects et
induits soit interne soit directement
peu importe mais l'objectif numéro un
c'est pas c'est pas de créer de créer
des emplois ce parce que à ce moment là
roux frais en il serait intervenir à des
formes d'énergie archaïque sous les ères
créera encore plus d'emplois dans ses
passes à la main alors par contre le
coût est un argument importe le coût du
démantèlement
nicolas sarkozy a donné un chiffre un
bonnet moi de vous couper il a parlé de
devis milliards je crois c'est ça est-ce
que et donc des chiffres c'est entre
cinq et huit milliards d'euros a dit à
nicolas sarkozy et
comment elle s'appelle ségolène royal
voilà la mise de l'écologie a dit c'est
totalement farfelue elle s'appuie sur un
rapport qui parlait plutôt de 5
milliards d'euros elle dit que c'est
déjà beaucoup trop par rapport au coût
réel est ce que vous avez un chiffre le
coût technique de d'installations de
production de deux centrales nucléaires
qui ont été totalement démantelé dans le
monde ces quelques centaines de millions
d'euros
c'est ça le l'ordre de grandeur par
contre ce dont parlait probablement
nicolas sarkozy c'est de la perte
économique lié au fait que vous fermez
avant l'heure une installation parce que
ça c'est de l'ordre de quelques
milliards d'euros dont je vous dise à
face à ce coup du démantèlement
alors oui les milliards c'est sûr que
non c'est sûr et si vous pensez à
quelque chose
associé à fessenheim qui pourrait valoir
quelques milliards d'euros le premier
truc qui vient à l'esprit c'est la perte
économique lié au fait que vous fermez
la centrale avant leur faudra alors je
cite un rapport parlementaire de 2014
qui avait évalué à 5 milliards d'euros
le démantèlement la fermeture de la
doyenne des centrales
oui non mais là où je suis d'accord avec
monsieur jancovici c'est que si on ferme
il est possible qu'il y ait une demande
indemnitaire mais ce dont parlait
nicolas sarkozy s'était pas de ça c'est
bien du démantèlement en cofondant du
reste allaigrement l'art à la mise à
l'arrêt le démantèlement qui sont deux
choses différentes mais passons sur le
démantèlement lui même c'est très
amusant de l'entente de citer ce chiffre
parce que je rappelle quand même que la
droite s'est battu pour faire croire que
le coût total du démantèlement en france
ce serait 13 milliards d'euros pour les
58 réacteurs ou 15 milliards d'euros
alors entendre monsieur sarkozy dire que
ça va coûter 5 à 8 milliards l'unité
c'est quand même assez risible bon ceci
étant ce qui est vrai c'est que si vous
prenez les bases anglaise ou suédoise
qui sont les plus sérieuses pour
l'évaluation du coût du démantèlement
vous êtes à plusieurs milliards de
l'unité et je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord que dit monsieur jancovici
la meilleure preuve en est je
terminerais là dessus que brennilis en
france qui est en cours de démantèlement
depuis 1984 une paille était parti sur
un coût de 100 millions au départ on est
pratiquement au milliards aujourd'hui et
c'est pas fini
combien ça représente en termes de
production
électricité fessenheim est ce que c'est
très important pour pour l'alsace
notamment est ce que l'un d'entre vous
pour répondre à cette question de deux
réacteurs de 900 mégawatts sur 58
réacteurs dans ça représente 2 sur 58
dont la région si la question qui était
posée c'est est ce que si on ferme fait
c'est dingue ça pose un problème pour la
gestion du réseau
la réponse est non parce qu'on par quoi
on remplace on peut faire appel à
d'autres centrales sont ils ont fait
appel à d'autres centrales qui sont un
peu plus rogné donc a pas de problème de
déséquilibre dû résoudre le problème
n'est pas là alors sur le démantèlement
sur démantèlement c'est vrai qu'il ya le
contre exemple de bonnes idées ça je
suis d'accord brennilis et un peu le
contre exemple sur le coût du
démantèlement
la commission énergie 2050 la question a
été posée
moi je veux m'appuyer sur un rapport
qu'il rapport la cour des comptes parce
que la cour des comptes un organisme
tout le monde respecte en considérant
que c'est des gens sérieux et ils ont
accès en plus aux informations
la cour des comptes dans son rapport
2012 puis 2014 dit le coût de
démantèlement
alors on en tient compte dans les
calculs parce que et d'être
approvisionné mais la cour ajoute la
faut être honnête la cour ajoute on
n'est pas certain que les provisions
soit suffisante
donc la cour ne dis pas parce que
beaucoup de gens disent on ne tient pas
compte du tout du coup dès maintenant
c'est faux on en tient compte que des
provisions à la fois pour le
démantèlement des centrales et pour la
gestion des modèles assez 15 mia mais
alors là le débat s'est alors mais
aujourd'hui honnêtement personne ne peut
répondre de façon affirmative cela et si
on voulait les trop où s'est passé
personne ne s'est pas trop là c'est sûr
la cour et prudente
et si on voulait le faire ce serait pas
une question de financement on est
d'accord avec ça non parce qu'on cherche
à représenter un pourcentage models
d'accord alors en tout cas la question
de la fermeture de fessenheim est au
coeur des discussions entre les écolos
et le présent de la république et la
question du retour des verts au
gouvernement s'est transformée en guerre
de tranchées chez europe ecologie les
verts de lille s'affrontent les amis de
cécile duflot qui refusé les compromis
sur l'écologie et sur la ligne
économique et social et les
parlementaires autour du sénateur jean
vincent placé qui sont prêts à intégrer
une équipe face au nom de la volonté de
fer et de peser
de l'intérieur le débat interne est sur
le point de faire exploser le parti par
des aztèques arnaud fort avec lise
barcellini et guillaume biro la sortie
progressive du nucléaire
c'était la promesse phare le totem de
l'accord entre verts et socialistes
trois ans plus tard la date de la
fermeture de fessenheim n'est toujours
pas fixé et la loi sur la transition
énergétique qui doit acter la réduction
de la part du nucléaire dans le mix
électrique n'est toujours pas votée une
situation qui divise les écologistes des
courants contraires où certains voient
encore le verre à moitié rose comme
denis baupin je pense que le
gouvernement il a défendu les textes
tels qu'on les avaient calées quoi c'est
à dire 2025 sur le nucléaire c'est 50%
de nucléaire par des pas à la fois à
l'assemblée nationale c'était très clair
c'est grisant dial d'ailleurs c'est de
s'exprimer de façon claire sur un
désaccord que nous avons nous on est
pour la sortie du nucléaire elle elle
dit qu'elle n'est pas pro la sortie du
nucléaire est ce que je comprends que
c'est la position des socialistes mais
sur le fait qu'il faut diversifier et
réduire la vulnérabilité de la france au
tout nucléaire
il fait partie de ceux qui se verraient
bien nos gouvernements il faut bien
évidemment toujours mieux être à
l'intérieur
s'il faut pas faire politique c'est
respectives ne pas faire de politique on
peut être dans le milieu associatif et
puis je me dis tu es tu sais je les fais
pendant des années beaucoup de gens le
font mais si on fait de la politique
c'est pour assumer la responsabilité de
prendre des décisions de participer au
pouvoir après les élections
départementales
une réunion est d'ores et déjà prévue
avec les verts favorables à un retour au
gouvernement mais aussi d'autres forces
écologique et la question à l'ordre du
jour sera quelle responsabilité pour les
écologistes
pascal canfin ancien ministre n'y
participera pas lui voit surtout le
verre à moitié vide et ne se fait plus
d'illusions sur les promesses
présidentielles dans ce combat qui est
en cours qui est en cours est-ce que
c'est nous qui allons gagner
est ce que c'est ce fait que areva sont
en faillite qui va s'imposer comme une
évidence qu'il faut changer de modèle
ou est ce que c'est les lobby
traditionnel qui vont l'emporter jeu
c'est pas je ne sais pas et le fait que
je ne réponde pas il y à une un
engagement du président de la république
donc ça va se faire c'est évidemment
parce que nous en doutons et si nous en
doutons c'est parce que des choses ont
été dites dites et redites et jamais
fait et que c'est ça le coeur du sujet
c'est qu'à un moment donné il faut être
en cohérence entre les actions et les
discours nous ne demandons rien de plus
pour autant le parti ne ferme pas la
porte au dialogue avec les socialistes
et souhaitent éviter l'éclatement partir
agiront rester et à quelles conditions
difficile aujourd'hui de sa peau
dalit et d'un retour au pouvoir et le
poids du nucléaire dans la discussion
des cils duflot la présence au
gouvernement n'est pas nécessaire pour
faire évoluer la société sur une claire
ce qui est sûr c'est que la loi sur la
transition énergétique a été discutée à
l'automne dernier nous n'étions plus au
gouvernement
mais par la force de conviction par
j'allais dire la réalité qui rattrape le
discours des écologistes
on a fait avancer les choses sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
soutien aux énergies renouvelables
le fait de lever les freins que depuis
des années on a mis en place notamment
pour lutter contre le développement de
l'éolien en france
on a fait avancer les choses quand on
écologistes et qu'on se bat depuis des
années pour la sortie du nucléaire on a
intérêt à avoir sacrément d'espoir
proches dans un pays qui a été
claquemuré intellectuellement y compris
les dirigeants politiques sur le côté
inamovible nucléaire qui est pourtant
une exception française à ces funestes
finalement parce qu'elle elle nous
enfermer elle nous empêche d'évoluer et
l'espoir pourrait paradoxalement venir
de l'ump en prenant fait et cause pour
la centrale de fessenheim
nicolas sarkozy pourrait pousser
françois hollande à prendre le contre
pied et tenir finalement sa promesse
alors justement à propos de la promesse
la fermeture de fessenheim aura-t-elle
lieu avant la présidentielle de 2017 et
sera t-elle irréversible quand il plonge
déjà en décidant que ce serait en 2010
est par là même il y a un doute sur les
réversibilité
si le président de la république l'avait
fait en 2015 c'était c'était acquis en
2017 vous vouliez très bien que je viens
ici ça ce mois d'avril est commode maya
notre président dans les deux mois il
peut revenir dessus et c'est
parfaitement légal donc déjà la date
elle-même pour moi a toujours été un
sujet de doute
deuxièmement comme ça a été rappelé
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a dit
c'est bon le conseil d'état parce que
delphine batho a très mal joué sur la
procédure qui avait été intentée par les
collectivités étrangères a dit il n'y a
pas de risque donc on ne peut pas fermer
pour le risque est à mon avis et c'est
le seul vrai motif donc ensuite vous
tombez dans des motifs politiques ça
c'est pas mon avis ça tient pas la route
des accords composer un gouvernement
pour l argent
ce qui tient la route c'est un projet de
stratégie énergétique c'est-à-dire de
dire comme le disait daniel bois tout à
l'heure bon il ya un horizon 2025 mais
on fait quoi en 2030 on fait quoi en
2035 ont fait feu en 2040 donc de dire
voilà on est parti sur une réduction
programmée du nucléaire
on est à temps à telle époque attend à
telle époque attend est à l'époque ça
veut dire fermer les centrales at elle
ri peu ça veut dire développer le
renouvelable at-elle rythme et c'est ça
c'est une vraie stratégie mais de dire
je vais fermer une centrale moi je suis
pour vous êtes vous irez pro nucléaire
mais simplement je trouve que le faire
comme ça tout seul sans qu'on ait une
logique autour c'est extrêmement
difficile ce serait toujours ça tri n'en
sait toujours ce même alors vous avez
dit en gros c'est la politique
politicienne mais si ça fait avancer la
cause écologique qu'est ce que vous en
dites oui daniel bois il ya un exemple
on a peut-être un petit peu oublié dans
l'accord entre les verts et le ps abouti
à la fermeture de créer smallville créé
smallville alors c'était pas simplement
cette fois ci c'est plus compliqué ce
n'est pas n'importe quelle centrale
c'était une nouvelle filière qu'étaient
les surgénérateurs où il y avait des
incertitudes cetera mais c'est arrivé
donc il ya eu un deal entre eux à ces
peuples entre le ps et les verts sur le
fait de fermer la centrale n'a été
fermée chrismale vilas les verts ont pas
obtenu par moi même avant même sans deux
parce que mais non parce qu'il ya eu un
arrêt du conseil d'état qui a annulé le
décret et j'ai refusé de signer un
décret de démarrage et en mettant ma ma
présence au gouvernement j'en ai mal
j'ai démissionné parce que ce que dit
aussi daniel vois c'est que au fond des
accords politiques peuvent permettre
bain de de construire une stratégie
énergétique
oui sauf je reviens sur des couleurs ce
que le sauf que l'accord entre les verts
et le ps de mon point de vue il a fait
ça qu'à moitié
parce que dira simplement l'accord entre
les verts et le ps ça consiste à dire
que en 2025 on sera 50% de l'électricité
nucléaire
oui d'accord mais c'est une question
mais ce n'est pas la vraie question
la vraie question c'est au bout des
quarante ans qu'est-ce qu'on renouvelle
à 60 ans comme font les américains
ou est ce qu'on construit de nouvelles
centrales ou est ce qu on fait
l'hypothèse que par miracle à ce moment
là on aura de l'énergie renouvelable qui
remplacera les centrales c'est ça la
vraie question c'est la question qui n'a
pas été discuté dans la loi dans le
débat sera transition énergétique et je
pense sa part été discuté
pour des vraies raisons c'est à dire que
on n'arrive pas encore une fois se
projeter à cet univers là ce à ce futur
là on n'arrive pas à prendre des
décisions parce que l'accord verts ps
n'était pas suffisamment profonds
évidemment sur pour arriver à dire
vraiment quel serait l'avenir au delà de
cette réduction à 50% que même des medef
semble pas tellement gêné en fait par
cet accord et vous mettez le doigt sans
doute sur l'une des questions que se
posent les gens qui nous regardent c'est
au fond le nucléaire serait peut-être
pas terrible c'est dangereux ça des
inconvénients fin vous en a bien compris
qu'il y avait un débat entre vous mais
qu'est ce qui lie à après vous avez posé
la question et je voudrais vous poser
cette interrogation d'un téléspectateur
ou d'une téléspectatrice combien
d'éoliennes faudrait-il pour remplacer
fessenheim à 3,10 à qu'il faut poser la
question pourquoi c'est pas comme ça
pardonnez moi c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut poser la question d'abord parce
qu'on est dans une politique
d'efficacité de la panique la réponse
parle on vous la connaissez la réponse
ne leur est pas que des éoliennes il y
aurait il y aurait mille et deux mille
vous disent à peu près oui il y aurait
des éoliennes mais c est faisable
il y aurait du solaire un sourire claude
masse des éoliennes c'est pas
inconcevable mais c'est pas gratuit
alors quelques éléments de cadrage
pour commencer il ya souvent en france
une idée qui est si on est écolo on est
anti nucléaire est ce que vous savez
quels sont les premiers consommateurs
d'électricité nucléaire par personne au
monde
les suédois qui par ailleurs n'utilise
pas de gaz dans le chauffage n'utilise
pas de pétrole dans chauffage n'utilise
pas de gaz et de pétrole et de charbon
dans leur industrie
donc qui recourent énormément à
l'hydroélectricité donc le renouvelable
et à la biomasse donc l'idée sympathique
selon laquelle si on est écolo on est
anti nucléaire est une idée très
française
il ya des tas de pays dans le monde dans
lequel s'est absolument pas vrai si vous
lisez les travaux de quelques
précurseurs de l'écologie et notamment
de l'équipe qui avait conduit un truc
qui s'appelle le rapport du club de rome
qui rappellera nuageuse au vieux le
nucléaire était du côté des solutions
écolo à cette époque donc le et les
onglets et les anglais quand vous leur
demandez quelle est l'énergie dans
laquelle il faut investir le plus génial
le plus bel effet avec le nucléaire en
tête d'accor et les chinois continuent à
le faire etc
mais c'est pas la question quatre ans
c'est vraiment comment ranger avec le
jeu contient d'énergie cette question là
n'est pas posée à cause de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire si
vous êtes écolo vous êtes anti nucléaire
donc fermer le ban et on passe à je ne
sais pas quoi du reste le la bonne
question
c'est à quoi sert l'énergie
quel est le bon compromis entre la
quantité qu'on veut en avoir les
inconvénients d'en avoir beaucoup parce
qu'il se trouve que l'énergie avec des
finitions physx est une grandeur
physique à l'énergie avant d'être un
sujet de débat l'énergie et la
transformation par définition physique
c'est la marque de la transformation
donc plus vous avez d'énergie plus vous
transformez du coup plus vous avez les
avantages de la transformation mais plus
vous avez ses inconvénients
d'accord on pouvait pas beaucoup de
transformer sans avoir beaucoup d'effet
à côté les énergies sympathique en
général sur les énergies qu'on utilise
la toute petite dose comme ça il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'inconvénients
puisqu'elles sont utilisés la toute
petite dose le solaire le photo l éolien
etc
pour le moment c'est dès tout petit
énergie à l'échelle mondiale vous n'y
croyez pas c'est pour elle une énergie
de substitution à terme ce que je dis
c'est que si c'est tout petit par
définition ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'inconvénients car j'ai tout fait pour
finir ce tout petit alors pour finir
là-dessus pour l'instant c'est sans
doute ce que je voulais dire c'est pour
l'instant c'est en suisse 40 % par an
pour l'instant mais oui mais quand c'est
tout petit + 40 % par an ça fait jusqu'à
nucléaire en chine donc vous gargarisez
c'est qu'on vire au noir sans schiller
par la vente de trombone les trombones
peuvent augmenter de 40% par an pendant
un certain temps ça vend alors on avance
du coudon sur le renouvelable
est ce que c'est la question que vous
gagnez un chiffre issu de l'observation
le programme allemand qui en gros a pour
objectif d'essayer de remplacer
prioritairement le nucléaire part des
renouvelables est pour le moment le
laquais du charmant prince un nom la
question climatique et pendant le sujet
c'est juste pas dans le sujet alors ça
monte un peu une année ça descend un peu
une autre mais on est dans des
fluctuations
ils ont pour le moment fermé huit
réacteurs
ils ont mis sur la table à peu près 300
milliards d'euros d'investissements
libyens 300 milliards c'est à dire à peu
près la valeur de reconstruction à neuf
du parc nucléaire français
il est à peu près pour produire 18 % de
leur électricité à partir de
renouvelables et les dispositifs qu'ils
utilisent vivent deux à trois fois moins
longtemps qu'une centrale nucléaire
ce faisant ils ont fichu le pastis sur
le marché de l'électricité
parce que vous quand vous regardez
comment ça se passe vous pouvez vraiment
dire que le prix dépend du sens du vent
en l'occurrence part du centre et de la
quantité
ils ont créé des engorgements sur les
interconnexions aux frontières à tel
point que les tchèques ont fini par dire
si vous continuez on va couper le réseau
à la frontière tchèque
parce que plus supporter vous êtes en
train de démontrer que je ne peux pas en
sortir
je suis en train de vous démontrer que
si on veut en sortir
ça va coûter très cher on peut le faire
c'est pas d'un jet physiquement c'est
possible
ce que je dis juste simplement c'est
qu'il faut que les gens comprennent que
la contrepartie c'est que les
investissements vont être multipliées
par 10 à 30 et que voilà et tous les
investissements voiture utilisée par dix
et apercevoir dont le combat du mix
énergétique un os pour la solution c'est
la somme rien gagné sur les émissions
françaises
alors la solution elle est sans doute
pas dans des éoliennes qui remplace des
centrales nucléaires on a bien compris
que l'idée cette construire une
stratégie énergétique à long terme et de
concerts un mix énergétique
quels sont les énergies d'avenir est-ce
que vous conseillez vous considérez que
le nucléaire est une énergie d'avenir
mais au delà alors je considère que le
nucléaire c'est une énergie d'avenir ça
veut pas dire pour autant que on ne peut
faire confiance aux dockers une claire
aujourd'hui c'est 12 % de la production
d'électricité à l'échelle mondiale or
c'est beaucoup en france et 75 %
alors non de la progression s'est
entraîné un strict plan de la production
d'électricité c'est 12% les chiffres
sont des fous et mes énergies ces 4 %
vous parler d'énergie primaire
moi je parle de production d'électricité
donc c'est bien 12% de la production et
ça va augmenter on est d'accord il ya
les pays qui vont y venir un second pc
pape à beaublanc car si on fait beaucoup
de centrales à côté attendez l'inde la
chine gros match et ici même déjà il
faut il y en a qui chantera le charbon
que centrale nucléaire donc si vous leur
pourcentage augmente pas beaucoup parce
qu'ils font plus de charbon et des
centrales à gaz
non ce que je veux dire c'est que le
problème des renouvelables c'est ce sont
pour l'instant des énergies
intermittentes temps qu'on sait pas
stocker l'électricité on a un problème
et est renouvelable
l'exemple très simple c'est les
allemands ont investi dans l'éolien et
le photovoltaïque une puissance qui est
supérieur à la puissance nucléaire
française
au delà de 63 gigawatts mais ça ne
produit que un peu plus de 20 pour cent
vingt marques et doivent être à 24%
maintenant nous allons monter soi même
% de leur production d'électricité non
et v12 juste et orientée bcbso le nom il
ya du gaz avec une bataille d'experts
et alors alors que la france on est à 75
points forts non non je pense que s'ils
voulaient si on veut avoir une vision
sur l'avenir du nucléaire la france pour
des raisons historiques et notamment de
recherche de l'indépendance a joué la
carte du nucléaire eon avis a été un bon
choix
le problème c'est qu'on est probablement
un seuil qui est peut-être excessif
alors ça que ça veut dire que on peut
très bien réduire la voilure 50% en 2025
non je dis on peut réduire de 50 % de
vie d'un sac mon avis c'est irréaliste
parce qu'on a me faudrait fermer il en
2025 c'est demain il faudrait il
faudrait fermer 20 centrale d'un coût
similaire va pas fermer la centrale les
objectifs on le rappelle il est maintenu
dans la transition énergétique en ça
fait quand même partie des choses qui
sont répéter répéter chaque jour mais on
peut on peut mettre des choses dans les
lois puis ensuite on regarde ce qui se
passe mais je dirais ça me paraît
complètement con réduisent un peu la
voilure
quelque chose ne s'absentera choquant
mais je pense dans le nucléaire faut
bien voir que y'a pas que les réacteurs
actuels et dont je m'appuie je m'appuie
sur une déclaration de madame ségolène
royal peut pas accuser d'être anti
nucléaire l'accueil en tout cas de ne
pas tenir compte des problèmes du
nucléaire
madame royal a fait une déclaration en
janvier disant que le nucléaire c'est l
avenir en france et notamment les
nouveaux raquette à joris je vous
remercie pour la transition nous allons
parler d'eux le père qui devait être la
vitrine de l'excellence française en
matière d'industrie nucléaire
mais sur les quatre centrales en
construction dans le monde 2 accumulent
de grosses difficultés celui de
flamanville
on est à cinq ans de retard et un coup
multiplié par 3 avec une facture de 8
milliards et demi
la livraison est donc reporté à 2017
avec la promesse de produire plus de
consommer moins de combustible le tout
avec une sécurité renforcée le dossier
avec maxime gauthier joël lefevre défis
technologiques on regarde
coincé entre une falaise de granit et la
manche
le chantier de la centrale nucléaire de
flamanville semble un peu prendre l'eau
après sept ans de travaux le réacteur
rpr nouvelle génération n'a toujours pas
démarré au contraire de la machine
judiciaire qui s'est emballé à 30 km de
là à cherbourg depuis lundi s'est ouvert
le procès des travailleurs de l'ombre
avec une question pour les avocats de la
cgt partie civile les centaines
d'ouvriers venus de pologne et de
roumanie présents sur ce chantier hors
norme
etait-il tous dûment déclaré on a eu
affaire à un système à mon avis organisé
entre des entreprises de travail
temporaire artificiellement domicile et
dans certains pays et notamment à chypre
qui détache des salariés polonais pour
les envoyer sur le site de le br de
flamanville en france donc par le biais
d'une utilisation dévoyée de certaines
règles européennes qui de toute façon
n'ont pas été respectées donc c'est
laisser le problème de notre
réglementation tant européenne que
nationale et des contrôles qu'on met
pour vérifier que certains salariés
étrangers sont employées correctement
sur notre pays
si la question du statut de ces
travailleurs détachés est un point
central du procès elle met surtout en
exergue les difficultés rencontrées
depuis de nombreuses années pour le
groupe bouygues et prestataires de
services en charge d'une partie des
travaux est aujourd'hui sur le banc des
accusés la mauvaise gestion du chantier
a mené à cet imbroglio juridique il est
apparu au bout de deux ans que le
scanner dit envisager notamment sur le
plan des armatures ski sur plan de la
sûreté de la sécurité quelque chose
d'essentiel était bien en deçà des
nécessités au point que gilles apparaît
que le nombre de tonnes d'armatures en
définitive a plus que doublé et les
moues ressources à mettre en oeuvre des
énergies déployées ont plus que doublé
et ça s'est produit dans des conditions
où il y avait les mêmes exigences de
délais et de planning
on n'a pas trouvé dans les délais qui
était exigée suffisamment d'entreprises
en france ou de salariés employés
ferrailleurs en france pour faire face à
des exigences exceptionnelles en pro
matière de quantité de qualité et de
délais il faut dire que le gigantesque
chantier de le p r accumule depuis
plusieurs années retard sur retard prévu
pour 2012
la mise en route du réacteur de
troisième génération de flamanville ne
devrait pas se faire avant 2017 en
difficulté le groupe areva concepteur du
réacteur ne parviendrait pas selon edf a
livré à temps les pièces essentielles
comme les structures internes à l'as tu
vois résultat le coût du chantier
explose prévu à hauteur de 3 milliards
d'euros il en coûtera finalement au
moins le triple on sera très proche des
10 milliards
donc on est dans un une gabegie
absolument formidable il faut arrêter
les frais la vitrine du nucléaire à la
française proche de se fissurer en
finlande à olkiluoto le père se fait
toujours attendre
il devrait être prêt en 2018 avec neuf
ans de retard sur le calendrier initial
et 5 milliards d'euros d'excédent selon
les experts la note pourrait être même
plus salée si comme il l' avance
chaque année de retard could be
plus de 700 millions d'euros areva les
chiffres astronomiques qui contribue en
grande partie aux pertes records d'areva
pour l'exercice 2014 près de 5 milliards
d'euros
l'occasion pour philippe varin de
remettre en cause la stratégie du groupe
sur les dernières années areva est en
situation de crise cette crise résulte
d'une conjonction de facteurs les
décisions malheureuses une déficience
dans la gestion de certains grands
projets un manque d'adaptation à
l'évolution des marchés
après l'accident de fukushima les
avaries de le p r catastrophe
industrielle en perspective ou
péripéties inévitables lors des
chantiers d'une telle envergure
des incertitudes qui n'ont pas découragé
nos voisins britanniques
on serait intéressé par l'achat de deux
ep r de l'autre côté de la manche
vous y croyez à 2017 le premier repère
qui entrerait en activité en france
j'étais ingénieur m'enfin ça me paraît
quand même très mal barré kg de ses 9
ans même en chine où on est en
joint-venture minoritaires ce à deux ans
de retard et pourtant c'est en chine et
avec leur ex chinois alors vous citez
l'angleterre évidemment c'est edf qui
est en angleterre
winch énergie sa partie à edf mais est
ce que on a bien compris que vous
n'étiez pas pro nucléaire ça jusque là
les choses sont claires
mais est-ce que ça malgré tout ça peut
être l'avenir du nucléaire mais celui là
sûrement pas là ensuite on peut parler
des petits réacteurs c'est ce dont
parlait monsieur percebois tout à
l'heure c'est à dire l'atmea des plus
petits réacteurs
moi je pense que franchement c'est pas
une filière d'avenir que la filière
d'avenir c'est le solaire c'est ça la
grande filière d'avenir et quand vous
regardez la manière dont au niveau
mondial aujourd'hui les les
développements se font les croissances
ce fonds c'est sur le solaire et dans
tous les pays du monde
le chine la chine fait un peu de
nucléaire c'est vrai 2% mais eux du
bouquet énergétique chinois c'est
vraiment anecdotique c'est vrai mais
vous avez vous êtes revenu sur rodez en
disant oui ans
c'est normal qu'ils aillent faire du
nucléaire tant mieux tant mieux sur bono
sinon je me plains pas mais simplement
ce que je dis c'est qu'on n'a pas vendu
l'angleterre c'est pas vraiment une
vente tous les autres et c'est normal
qu'est ce que vous voulez on n'est pas
capable de montrer ce qu'on est capable
de faire chez nous comment voulez vous
que les autres l'achète ya aucune raison
quand même et ils sont pas cuits alors
si delhaize ou vous dites vous quand
vous voyez le projet un prs que vous
dites c'est l'avenir de la filière il
faut avancer fois les plus vite s'il
faut lever les obstacles alors lepers et
troisième génération alors c'est un
réacteur qui se veut extrêmement
sécurisé et n'oublions pas que c'est une
tête de série alors il ya eu des erreurs
au départ qui tiennent au fait qu' areva
a été extrêmement je dirais ambitieuse
et à penser que ça marche la très vite
qui pourrait construire présente le p r
en finlande en quatre ans et un coût de
3 milliards ou 4 milliards alors qu'ils
ont complètement sous-estimé alors voilà
c'est un héros de type qu'on est en
train de construire et c'est pour ça que
c'est l'on excepté un seul mick ya eu
une erreur stratégique erreur satellite
et n'oubliez pas qu'en france on a
construit 58 réacteurs en 25 ans
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque on avait un
schéma industriel très cohérent on avait
un maître d'oeuvre qui était sdf on
avait la cogema qui s'occupait de
l'uranium en amont et en aval donc du
combustible et on avait framatome qui
construisaient les réacteurs et tout ça
avec un chef d'orchestre qui a fait que
en standardisant avec une grande
expérience on a fait un parc de
production qui est efficace
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a fait à partir
de 2001 on a fusionné le combustible que
gemma avec framatome une petite partie
du sérail et on a créé areva et arriva
en quelque sorte si cru un peu
indépendante et à mon avis a fait une
erreur stratégique il n'était pas maître
d'oeuvre ils ont voulu construire tout
seul sans et des f1 recteur en finlande
sauf que ils n'ont pas l'habitude il
n'avait pas l'habitude et sont pas il
faut pas marcher des réacteurs alors à
l'international quand rob à abu dhabi et
que areva y va tout seul alors qu'il
faut pas marcher des recteurs les gens
comprennent pas pourquoi des faits pas
dans le coup donc si vous voulez on sait
il ya une erreur stratégique à ce niveau
là donc aujourd'hui ça explique que le
gouvernement à me réveiller à juste
titre 10
areva et edf bon maintenant vous
remarcher un peu ensemble pour que sur
le plan industriel ça fonctionne au mur
ceci étant je suis d'accord pour dire
que troisième génération il ya le père
je pense qu'après les autres réacteurs
ça ira probablement mieux on va voir ce
que font les chinois parce que les
chinois ils sont à peu près dans les dés
et quand même enfin ils sont moins en
retard que nous en tout cas sont minces
mais il ya d'autres réacteurs notamment
l'atmea milles alors un carré va
probablement d'autres cartes à jouer et
l'atmea mille de même qu'il ya une très
forte concurrence à l'international
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de compétiteurs
à savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya des tas de
gens qui proposent des acteurs à
commencer par les chinois un petit mot
sur sur ce qu'on vient de dire et je
voudrais avoir votre action sur ce que
dit anne lauvergeon elles disent aussi
il ya eu un problème c'est l'état
actionnaire qui à un moment donné a pas
fait ce qu'il fallait faire alors pour
pour compléter ce que vient de dire
jacques percebois et pour bien
comprendre le métier de maître d'oeuvre
est un métier dans lequel vous prenez la
responsabilité de l'ensemble des
opérations et en particulier des choses
qu areva faisait pour la première fois
comme par exemple couler le béton c'est
quelque chose qui faisait pas traiter
avec les autorités de tout un tas de
procédures administratives
d'autorisation et cetera qui était avant
un truc qui faisait pas et c'est ce
nouveau métier qu'ils ont voulu faire en
même temps qu'un nouveau réacteur qui
fait qu' ils n'ont pas réussi
voilà juste aussi pour rappeler il n'est
pas rare que les choses qu'on fait pour
la première fois voient leurs coûts
explosent et le tunnel sous la manche
n'importe quel développement
informatique pour ceux qui connaissent
enfin bon c'est des choses qui arrivent
assez assez souvent y compris dans le
monde pétrolier aussi bien dans le
pétrolier il ya un gisement caspienne
s'appelle kashagan le budget initial
était de 6 milliards de dollars ils sont
rendus à 45 donc c'est enfin voilà donc
c'est quelque chose qui est pas rare on
va dire et qui n'est pas propre
nucléaire alors après sur la question
qui a été posée qui met déjà sorti de la
tête de puit tant que cause l'avenir de
la filière je disais en gros anne
lauvergeon dit oui mais c'est parce que
l'état actionnaire à passer le le
travail là aujourd'hui on voit bien que
l'état dit il faut qu'un rapprochement
entre edf et areva est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça mais alors ce qui
n'aide pas et ça renvoie au début de
l'émission c'est le fait que le discours
politique sur le nucléaire n'est pas
stable dans le temps n'est pas carré
industriellement et n'est pas calée sur
des objectifs dont on comprend pourquoi
donc ça renvoie au début de l'émission
le nucléaire faut-il en faire ou pas il
ya une première question qui est où est
ce que je le mets dans les hiérarchies
des choix énergétiques qui sont
possibles chez moi donc on peut souvent
le débat en france et nucléaire contre
éolien
mais il ya aussi par exemple nucléaire
contre gaz il faut savoir que les
suédois se chauffe énormément et de la
pompe à chaleur alimenté avec de
l'électricité
ça c'est une solution qui est
concurrente du gascon peu utilisé par
ailleurs pour se chauffer france avec
les énergies fossiles
aussi il ya une concurrence nucléaire
charbon dans le monde et c'est donc où
est ce qu'on met dans les choix et ça ça
dépend du coup ça dépend de la
dangerosité sa dépendent
et c'est une fois politique et les choix
politiques dans un pays éclairés devrait
intégrer je ne dis je dis pas de ré ce
qu'alice sûr mais devrait au moins
intégré les faits documentés et le monde
tel qu'il se présente
or en france c'est difficile c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche et du coup vous
avez un discours hésitant qui n'aide pas
à avoir une stratégie industrielle
c'est absolument évident et nous allons
passer maintenant caisse m
je ne veux pas de centrales nucléaires
près de chez moi ni de lignes à haute
tension ni même d'éoliennes mais je veux
l'électricité alors voilà c'est
classique 1 daniel bois oui il ya des
gens qui sont comme ça effectivement et
à l'idée que les choses doivent se
passer ailleurs j'aurais électricité
mais pas de centrale ceci dit quand on
regarde ce qui se passe autour des
centrales quand on interroge les gens
autour des centrales ils sont pour la
centrale parce que ils profitent
énormément des retombées économiques de
l'emploi etc
donc c'est pas si simple que ça il
n'empêche que dans notre pays comme dans
d'autres pays industriels il ya
maintenant un réflexe qui est un petit
peu un réflexe de pas chez moi plutôt
chez les autres indéniable bien sûr on a
vu ça donc là un endroit donc s'équiper
d'éoliennes vient problème c'est dingue
il ya quelque chose qui ce qui a bougé
en france je trouve depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est qu'on a commencé à mettre
en route des procédures commission
nationale du débat public pour aider un
petit peu à débattre des choses le calme
en bien comme mon avis c'est un progrès
parce qu'avant faisait passer le
bulldozer centraux discuter je dis pas
que c'est parfait mais c'est un progrès
ceci dit la société j'ai l'impression
que elle va dans l'autre sens c'est à
dire qu'elle est de plus en plus rétives
à ça pour des tas de raisons pour un
espèce de deux de divorce entre la
science et la société qui fait que même
si on a augmenté améliorer les
procédures le débat public
ça se passe pas toujours très bien aller
une autre question la menace terroriste
est elle un argument en faveur de la
fermeture de nos centrales
ça vous fait sourire je pense que la
personne qui pose cette question de
souris tard en posant la raison c'est
pas c'est pas une plaisanterie moi je
crois que c'est pas une plaisanterie du
tout on a le doigt sur vous les deux
centres avec des drones alors nos
centrales sont calculés pour pouvoir
résister à la chute d'un petit avion
mais pas d'un gros et nos piscines sont
calculés pour résister à la fuite de
rien du tout bon à part pour le père
parlait à part le p r oui mais les
autres
donc voilà il y investir et justes et un
mot sur la question précédente excusez
moi c'est que quand même vous avez de
plus en plus en france des communes
d'airé des collectivités locales qui
s'organisent pour l'autonomie
énergétique et qui font participer la
population et là ça marche mais il
yad'autres hier la question n'était pas
celle ci
je suis désolé en avant si vous voulez
bien ça a suscité le débat beaucoup
d'interrogations donc je voulais pause
dans quel état sont les réacteurs
français
dans quel état c'est à dire dans quel
état ils sont bons et ice en mauvais
état ils sont en revient à ce qui a été
dit on en revient à ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure il ya un dialogue
permanent en france entre l'exploitant
qui est des f où le cea où le cnrs parce
que vous avez aussi des installations de
recherche qui ne sont pas opérés par
appareil f et un gendarme qui s'appelle
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire et le la
loire a confié aux gendarmes le soin de
vérifier l'état dans lequel sont les
installations et de les autoriser à
poursuivre ou pas leur exploitation par
tranches de quelques années sous réserve
ou pas de faire un certain nombre de
travaux c'est là que de temps en temps
on leur dit ben voila vous investir le
débat entre l'opérateur et son médecin
entre guillemets est un débat très long
très technique et très complexe et qui
de ce fait est malheureusement très
difficilement accessibles aux obsar a
juste avoir la réponse à la question à
parler d'accords dont j'ai lu pas
d'accord et je sais m'adapter encore on
n'est plus à l'heure du débat en cours
au pardon dans quel état sont les
riverains on savait pas en bonne état
voilà la réponse conforme pour qu'ils
puissent fonctionner dit l'asn
bon allez avant supprimer le nucléaire
ne faut-il pas commencer par économiser
de l'énergie
on l'a peut-être pas suffisamment ce
débat sur wii simplement économiser
l'énergie
il ya l'efficacité énergétique et là
vous avez des tartines partout et puis
on arrive à la sobriété la sobriété qui
s'écrit la faire c'est vous c'est moi et
là c'est en trois lignes parce qu'on
sait pas comment ça fonctionne de
sobriété
comment va convaincre les gens de d'être
sobre du point de vue comme en valeur
convaincre par exemple que c'est pas 22
degrés mais 18 faut mettre un pull c'est
très très très difficile on n'a pas les
moyens parce que là c'est une action qui
est pas de l'action sur la technique
c'est la scion sur les gens et à la
persuasion il ya la taxation et des tas
de choses mais franchement dans les
rapports sur la transition énergétique
c'est le paragraphe qu'il plus minces
parce qu'on sait pas très bien comment
d'organiser ça il songe les mentalités
voilà changer de montagne ça commence
les d'école ça étant de la lumière oui
ça marche la sobriété en effet c'est une
chose mais quand même un potentiel
important d'efficacité à la fois dans
les transports et dans le bâtiment parce
que c'est quand même les deux gros
secteurs commencent à s'organiser à les
deux coups bien augmenterait ma facture
d'électricité en cas de suppression du
nucléaire est ce qu a eu des simulations
là dessus et en cas d'investissements
nécessaires sur le nucléaire parce que
il faut pas croire que ça va coûter rien
du tout le 2 mai de 100 milliards sur la
table pour mettre les centrales en
sécurité pour commencer et le récupère
et areva donc je crois qu'il faut
essayer d c'est un débat justement qu'on
n'arrive pas à voir qui est pas
rationnel sur les cours respectifs c'est
vrai que le renouvelable coûte
mais aujourd'hui on arrive à des prix de
revient du renouvelable qui sont
inférieurs aux prix de revient du
nucléaire nouvelle génération ça l'est
pas par quoi le remplacer oui si on
remplace par du charbon ça n'augmente
pas beaucoup dans les circonstances
actuelles à l'éolienne si on le remplace
par de l'éolien et du solaire je vais me
risquer à dire que ça augmenterait d'un
facteur 5 à 20 cents et sinon pauvres et
5 non mais c'est fourbe aller toute
façon on tranchera entre vous allez le
problème du nucléaire n'est ce pas avant
tout les déchets c'est un problème c'est
un problème parce que s'ils voulaient le
lien dans le nucléaire vous avez en
effet des déchets si on peut recycler
quelques-uns alors s'il avantage
d'ailleurs dé nouveau recteur et ce sur
quoi insistent et madame royal c'était
ça c'est à dire aujourd'hui il ya des
travaux de recherche sur des réacteurs
dits de quatrième génération
c'est-à-dire le projet astrid en france
ca qu'à ce moment là le plutonium que
vous obtenez vous pouvez leur cycle est
un multi recyclage est possible bon ceci
étant il restera des déchets
heureusement les déchets les plus
dangereux c'est un pour cent des déchets
il ya quand même un certain temps les la
loi prévoit que ces déchets très
dangereux doivent être enfouies donc
dans un site géologique profond de 500
mètres environ si vous voulez le
problème des déchets reste un problème
parce qu'on sait des choses on sait
qu'on devra les stocker bon alors on
espère peut-être que demain cas
nouvelles technologies une partie
pourrait être transmis thème est pour
l'instant égard n'est fait pour
l'instant il ya un problème
le problème n'est pas économique parce
que le coût d'enfouissement des déchets
même s'il augmente par rapport à ce
qu'il était avant si vous voulez ça
représente un pourcentage modeste du
prix de revient du kilowatt heure du
caire le problème c'est en effet il
reste des déchets qui ont une durée de
vie
je pense que nos téléspectateurs notre
téléspectatrices voulait pas non plus
habiter à côté d'un endroit où on stocke
des dessins du pied droit c'est un 100
mètres de profondeur vous risquez pas
grand chose ça devrait aller
arrivera-t-on un jour à stocker
correctement l'électricité oui c'est
déjà le faire le problème c'est que
c'est quelque chose qui est gourmand en
espace
aujourd'hui il ya dans le réseau
français des installations de stockage
qui sont des barrages réversible donc
c'est des barrages avec lesquels vous
avez une retenue en amont le fameux lac
de barrage et vous avez une retenue en
aval et vous faites circuler l'eau du
bas vers le haut quand vous avez de
l'électricité disponible par ailleurs et
ensuite vous restituer cette électricité
à un moment où vous en avez vraiment
besoin en turbines en lots d'angleterre
avec la nation les faire du système en
séchant palette on construire plus de
barrages en france c'est performant que
les anciens alors des nouveaux la
seconde de nouveaux barrages standard
il n'y a plus assez de pluie qui tombent
pour qu'on y arrive on va contre des
barrages réversible sans eau pour elle
mais ça occuperait beaucoup d espace
merci beaucoup aux à vous à tous même
malgré les débats je pense qu'on a un
petit peu avancé c'est la fin de cette
émission qui sera rediffusé ce soir à
22h25 lundi pour trouver axel de tarlé
pour c'est à dire il veut qu'elle vit à
17h50 pour ceux dans l'air quand à moi
je vous donne rendez vous dimanche 18h
pour ses politiques m'ont invité sera
jean christophe cambadélis très belle
soirée sur tf1